the academy of raya lucaria pretty much
if harry potter turned into a horror
film so many mysteries surround this
castle of sorcerers and when you take
your time to look around you start to
notice some reoccurring themes the first
thing you'll notice are cages
lots and lots of cages
some are big and some are smaller but
most of them are meant to cage a small
bird i can't tell what these birds are
meant for yet more than likely they're
messenger birds for the academy kind of
like the owls from harry potter but
could potentially be the giant birds
with the swords for talons that we see
at stormville castle maybe these birds
were stolen from the academy and used in
war for godric the golden but that's
just all speculation like most of these
lore videos will be please leave your
comments down below on what you think
all of these things could mean you
should also join our discord we're
always looking for more people to have
elden ring discussions with and would
love to have you in our community but
the academy is a strange place which is
a normal occurrence in the lands between
but when looking closer at the
environments of the academy it was
clearly a place for studying astrology
there are telescopes globes meteoric
crystal stones everywhere that the
people of this area seem to be
constantly studying and excavating the
giant elevators that we use on the
outskirts of the outdoor area of the
academy are likely used to dig giant
holes of dirt in order to find more of
these purple crystals some sorcerers
wear helmets with these purple crystals
these enemies are extremely rare in
comparison to the glimstone sorcerers
who we see much more often we can even
see a sorcerer's staff with the purple
crystal on the end of it these enemies
are stronger and pose much more of a
threat and these purple helmets or masks
are likely given to only those who have
really been at the academy for an
extremely long time and have mastered
many different spells making your way
further inside you'll notice these
glimstone masks of what i believe are
the former governors of the academy that
came before ranala who currently holds
the title of governor of the academy we
have some item descriptions that can
tell us who these former governors were
like alvinist conspectus the alvinous
glintstone crown description reads the
lineage of alvinous conspectus began
with the sorcerer lucette and its
adherents continue his study of meteors
which makes sense that there are many
examples of astrology throughout the
academy when a former governor founded
this study and its current governor
ranala is considered the queen of the
moon so there's obviously a huge
interest in why these sorcerers of the
lands between hold these crystals and
the study of astrology in general in
such high regard at the academy not that
anything looks clean or organized in the
lands between but the academy looks like
it's been in disarray books are thrown
around everywhere like there's a panic
to figure out something that has to do
with these crystals meteors and
astrology itself this is just my theory
but it likely has to do with ronnie the
daughter of ranala eg tells us that
ranny cannot continue her quest until
the stars above start to move again as
we all know at this point the stars are
controlled by general radon you can even
see in the item description of the spell
gravity well that the gravitational
technique was studied by the young radon
whose master was an albuster lord with
the skin of stone this tells us that
radon was a student of the academy or is
least a powerful sorcerer in his own
right and when you look at his moveset
that does start to make a lot of sense
he has the ability to control the stars
above which in ronnie's case stops her
from fulfilling her destiny it's likely
that ranala or possibly even ronnie
herself ordered the sorcerers of the
academy to start studying astrology so
that they too could control the stars
ranala is also obsessive towards her own
children so it would make sense that
she'd do this for her own daughter but
it does also seem that ronnie no longer
works or trusts her mother since she
decided to use us a tarnished of no
renown to kill radon for her so that the
stars can move again and she can
continue on her path however when we
first encounter ranala she doesn't seem
to be of right mind or
extremely obvious reasons we learned
from muriel at the church of vows that
ronald's heart was broken when ratagon
left her to marry marica
lord radigan was a great champion
possessed of flowing red locks
he came to these lands at the head of a
great golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle
he soon repented his territorial
aggressions there
and became husband to the carrion queen
however
when godfrey first elden lord was
hounded from the lands between
radigan left rinala to return to the
earth tree capital
becoming queen america's second husband
and king consort
taking the title
of second elden lord
the mystery endures to this day
as to why lord radicand would cast lady
ranala aside
and moreover
why a mere champion would be chosen for
the seat of eldon lord
you wish to know more of lady ranala
she is queen
head of the karyan royal family
and governor of the academy of real
lucaria
the great and beautiful full moon witch
sadly her heart was broken when lord
radican left her
and then when the academy rebelled
against the royals
she was locked away in the grand library
this makes a lot more sense when you
realize that there are no statues of
marca inside the academy with a broken
heart she likely resents queen marca for
taking ratagon away from her her state
of mind when we interact with her is
clearly unstable and maybe it's for good
reason we'll have to investigate her
side of the story much more there's a
hidden cave on the cliff side of the
academy that leads to a mine shaft of
creepy sorcerers and even more purple
crystals this man in a cage is also
quite interesting just one man in a cage
deep underneath the academy raises a lot
of questions for me what raises even
more questions is the boss fight you
find here as well two crystalline bosses
one with a spear and one with a staff my
katana didn't work on them whatsoever so
i decided to switch to a more blunt
weapon that seems to work against
crystal enemies the weapon i chose just
so happened to be radagon's hammer now i
don't know if these crystalline enemies
are weak to the golden order magic that
you get from weapons like this but it
definitely seemed like it the ash of war
on this hammer did a ton of damage and
staggered them every time i used it and
then i saw my summon use a katana that
did even more damage toward the end of
the fight so i have no idea what this
means at this point you receive the
crystal release spell upon defeating
this boss which reads this sorcery is
used by high ranking adepts among
crystallines some also call this sorcery
the crystal sun more astrology
references more astrological enemies and
as always i'm just getting more
questions i can't tell if this area down
here was built or found by the sorcerers
but if you continue through the doorway
you'll find a very long elevator that
takes you to an offset tower of the
academy at the top you'll find one chest
that carries the terra magica spell that
draws a sigil on the ground and gives
you a buff in magic damage when standing
inside of it there's no path to anywhere
else on this tower which again just
raises more questions for me why is
there just one random chest in this
random tower that i had to go underneath
the academy to get to it's almost as if
they were hiding it the academy of raya
lucaria is full of mystery and
environmental storytelling that honestly
raises more questions than answers i'd
love to hear what you all think down in
the comments and again join the discord
so we can have a conversation about all
things eldon ring you can also join my
twitch streams i stream all the time and
i'll be lore hunting and learning
everything i can about this incredible
game thank you all for watching i hope
you enjoyed it and i'll see you again
soon
you